In this problem, you're going to use the SIR model
to look at a situation in which people's immunity doesn't last.
In other words, after someone who has been infected moves to the recovered population.
Here, she can become susceptible again.
We're going to call this waning immunity and we'll set the constant over here waning time
to equal the amount of time that it takes for a person's immunity to fade away.
Most of the information we've given you in the supplied code you've seen before,
but there are couple of things that are particular to this unit.
You'll see another transmission coefficient,
which is a measure of how frequently each day, each infectious person might infect someone else.
You could also think of it as the likelihood that an interaction between an infected person
and a susceptible person went up with the susceptible person becoming infected.
Just make sure that you know that its unit is 1 per person per day
and the first thing that we want you to do is to define waning time right here.
So eventually we have a system in stead state
where the number of recovered people is equal to 2 times the number of infected people.
Think about what this means in terms of the time that people should spend infected
versus the time that they should spend recovering.
Just for reference, I've include the equations for the standard SIR model right here.
Remember that this equation don't include waning immunity.
First think about how you need to change them in order to reflect the situation at hand.
Once you figure that out, you'll need to translate your mathematical expressions into code.
We've already created list for S, I, and R for you.
And we set the initial values for susceptible, infected, and recovered populations right here.
Next comes a for loop, part of which you'll have to fill in.
We've given you S to I, right here,
which is a number of people moving from susceptible to infected during one-time step.
We've also given you I to R,
which is a number of people going from infected to recovered in a given time step.
What you need to do is to define R to S.
The number of people who in one-time step become susceptible again after they've recovered.
Just to be clear, all three of these are measured in number of people,
not in number of people per time.
Make sure that you check that your units are correct.
Your last task is to modify the recursive functions right here for S, I, and R.